because I live in probably you know  maybe next to San Francisco the most  liberal drug-friendly city in the United  States I mean we're one of the first  states to legalize cannabis we've  decriminalized almost all drugs we've  got stores openly selling mushrooms here  in Portland now uh you know outside the  law but nobody's doing anything and at  the same time our local County Board is  voting to ban the sale of flavored  nicotine pouches that are you do no harm  basically and can really help people  quit smoking so it's really frustrating  you know seeing this dichotomy of uh how  every other drug is treated as a  person's choice and is something that  should be least legal in some way and  nicotine which is pretty low risk once  you divorce it from inhaling a cigarette  is uh being you know not criminalized  but being made illegal to South